Just how did the Tyrannosaurus rex get from
oversized chicken to the colossal beast we
tend to see on the silver screen?
Well, we’re still digging for the answers.
Outside the confines of Jurassic Park, real-life
scientists are always updating our ideas about
what dinosaurs may have looked like, and we’re
constantly being surprised by their findings.
Like these brand new digital reconstructions
of what baby T. rex’s may have looked like,
giving us new insight into their life cycle.
And beyond our curiosity about their beautiful
exterior, related research has just revealed
that an early, ancestral species of T. rex
was actually tiny!
Like the size of a small deer!
Turns out, the iconic T. rex is an enigmatic
animal to understand.
To get us a little more situated in this story
we talked with Mark Norell, who’s been working
on understanding the details of dinosaur life
for his whole career.
He and his team have created digital reconstructions
of T. rex hatchlings, and guys—they’re
so cute.
And covered in feathers!
Mark Norell: “T. rex is kind of important
because it's really an anomalous animal.
There's nothing else really like it at all.
And now that we're starting to get enough
specimens of it that we can actually take
and really understand quite a bit about things
like its growth, things like that ... Habits,
maybe a little bit about diet.
but it's certainly, I mean,
Most dinosaur specimens we only have one specimen
of, or most dinosaur species.
But certainly with T. rex, we have 46 pretty
well preserved specimens now.”
Until recently we didn’t have that much
info about how the T. rex became the T. rex.
We knew they were a top end predator for about
15 million years up until their extinction
at the end of the Cretaceous period.
But when we try to go backward, before their
mighty reign of terror began, there’s about
a 70 million year gap between giant T. rex
and a medium-sized, primitive T. rex ancestor
we’d been able to unearth from the Jurassic
period.
There was just nothing in the fossil record
to indicate to us how, when, and how fast
T. rex went, in the words of one paleontologist,
‘from wallflower to prom king’.
So the chances of becoming a fossil are very,
very, very, very, very small.
Chances of being a well preserved fossil is
even much, much, much, much, smaller.
So we're working with not only a poor record,
but a record which is flawed, also in the
sense that small animals don't preserve as
large as big ones.
However—new fossils just unearthed in Utah
are helping us put together the pieces.
These specimens are now thought to be the
oldest Cretaceous tyrannosauroid remains ever
discovered in North America, and surprise!
They’re the much smaller and faster ancestor
of the huge, lumbering T. rex we know and
love.
This tiny ancestor of goliath is called Moros
intrepidus, which cheerfully translates to
“the harbinger of doom”.
It took this team 10 years of incredibly persistent
excavation to find this key organism, helping
us not only piece together T. rex lineage,
but also give us a sense of where they lived
and how they migrated through an ancient earth.
This update to the fossil record now tells
us that at some point, the T. rex must have
made the journey from Asia, the home the very
primitive tyrannasoid fossils we’d found
previously, to North America, where we’ve
found this new in-betweener.
In addition to improving our understanding
of where the T. rex came from and how it evolved
over time, we’re also starting to revisit
how they grew up.
What happens in between a baby T. rex hatching
and the full adult?
And WHY are its arms so tiny!?!
Mark: “I mean it grew to adult size in about
19 years, which is pretty remarkable..."
So that T. rex could grow to its immense size,
for a while it was growing over two kilograms
a day for quite a while during its lifetime.
So that's surprising.
As babies, the little stumpy T. rex arms were
more proportional to their body size, letting
them hold on to wriggling prey, like their
smaller tyrannosauroid ancestors.
But as they had to pack on more and more weight
even faster as they rose to prominence, more
of that development went to the head and neck,
specially designed to brutally crush their
prey...leaving the arms just.
Hangin’.
The past ten years have been full of advancements
to the computational and scientific tools
paleontologists use to analyze fossilized
remains.
Techniques like synchrotron radiation and
Raman spectroscopy represent non-invasive
imaging that let us see how the animals grew,
to be able to see and count the layers of
bone they put down every year.
Mark: "So on a computation and technology
side really a lot of has changed.
And it's changing really quickly now, just
as we speak."
Advancements in both excavation and analysis
are continuing for the T. rex niche of this
field and paleontology in general—we’re
starting to look at the fossil record in new
ways to help us gain a deeper understanding
of well, everything.
From the origins of these species to what
they looked like, what they ate, how they
interacted with each other, even what the
ancient atmosphere was like ...there’s just
a wealth of information out there waiting
to be dug up and discovered to tell us more
about our world and understand how we got
to today.
Might as well start with the T. rex, huh?
While we won’t be bringing dinosaurs truly
back to life any time soon, the American Museum
of Natural History is putting on quite the
show with their T. rex recreations so if you’re
in town you should check it out, or check
them out online at the link in the description.
Let us know what your favorite T. rex fact
is in the comments, and make sure you subscribe
to Seeker to find out what paleontologists
will unearth next.
As always, thanks for watching!